I need both these to destroy my soul and
these questions destroy my career that's
what I need out of the next five minutes
of this video what's up you beautiful
bastards hope you're having a fantastic
Thursday I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and at long last I'm joined by Philip
DeFranco he's a YouTube juggernaut new
media powerhouse you know him as the
host of the wildly popular philip
defranco show Phil Edie welcome to hot
ones it's long overdue thanks for having
me I once I sat down I actually saw it
in person rather than on video I got a
little nervous before we get started I
do want to say thank you for shouting us
out and today an awesome for all these
years really you were on the hot ones
bandwagon early on you're a great
interviewer and I like I like seeing
people in pain two of my favorite things
so I'm down I'm on it it is a different
experience but I'm ready
[Music]
all right so this first one is the
humble house okay that's right
so I start naturally by talking some
shop you've been one of the biggest
people on YouTube for a decade strong
and therefore have a unique perspective
when it comes to YouTube step by step
evolution what's the biggest difference
between a YouTube star and 20 18 versus
say 2010 age and accessibility right
when I was coming up it was it was
definitely 18 to like 45 right the the
biggest guy on YouTube at the time was
this this guy geriatric 1927 it's really
really old-school now I go to a VidCon
and there are 12 year olds that hopped
off on musically that are converting
over and they're the big thing and I
think that's what exquisite exciting
though is they can come in young
hopefully managed properly by parents
and and people who mean well but then
yeah it's it's a whole new world it's
also a weird world do you remember how
you discovered YouTube and what you were
watching at the time so is this old old
series called lonely girl 15 there was
this girl that appeared that she was
just a vlogger and then it turned out to
be this whole fake soap opera thing and
then I just kind of fell in love off of
youtube with talking cats thanks to say
Frank way way back in the day and then
when he stopped his show I want to make
a really bad version of that and I did
that for about four years and then
slowly found my my voice did the YouTube
community do as much whining back then
as we do today yeah it was just
different well cuz now we have business
issues back then we had sight completely
doesn't work I'm uploading a video it's
been three days like this thing's not
showing up there were a lot of creators
that hated that that Google purchased
YouTube but I was just like oh good
they're gonna have some money you're
gonna hopefully be able to figure stuff
out but ya know it's it's just less
broken what's one thing that you
definitely don't miss about YouTube's
formative years I like getting paid now
that's a big plus I did it for several
years just as a hobby just for fun
didn't make a cent was gonna when I was
gonna stop doing it back in the day it
was because it was
was killing my grades in college and
then one day YouTube said hey we're
getting 40 people we're gonna start
paying you guys money and they're like
it's gonna be a lot of money it was not
a lot of money I thought I made a
mistake for about two years but then
luckily it's Panda
[Music]
yeah we got this German trainers so the
state of journalism is something I feel
like I could talk to you about all day
and I'll start with this where should
people get their news everywhere if
you're not comparing and contrasting
you're getting one source it's one of
the reasons why one of my biggest things
is giving the facts I'm also giving my
opinion but it needs to be a jumping-off
point I don't want to do a blanket
statement right I think if there are a
lot of people trying their best that are
maybe working at organizations that
don't necessarily care about presenting
the full story as much as presenting a
narrative whether you're looking at
mainstream and sense of Fox News and CNN
all the way to a bright bar to a
Huffington Post and wherever you sit
down and read it feels like someone's
trying to make you think of thing if
Facebook is suffering from fake news
what's YouTube's corollary how are
Facebook and YouTube different is
information delivery systems near
they're not really both places the way
they're set up in general your your
getting your news based off an algorithm
right and it's a problem that YouTube
was talking about recently with with
with videos about conspiracy theories
the algorithm is trying to keep you on
site the algorithm favors you staying
here rather than going somewhere else
especially a competitor so if you are
interested in this kind of concept and
it might not be true it might be
sensational it might be crazy despite
what Robert Kensal says in an interview
with Casey Neistat
weave algorithm right now makes you want
to stay there and feeds you more of that
same content so it's really really
important once again to go out of your
way to try and get information
everywhere because if you're getting
information based off of an algorithm
you're just gonna stay in your bubble
[Music]
welcome so with the Philip DeFranco show
you're essentially publishing an op-ed
daily on a number of topics which is
like tiptoeing your way through a
cyberspace minefield when you think
about the times that you were totally at
odds with the Internet
what's the stance the opinion that left
you on an island I've talked about
religion I've talked about capital
punishment politics the most hate I've
ever received was way way back Metallica
had just there was like a lawsuit
against one of their fans we downloaded
other music and there and they were
suing them and that was the most
outrageous infuriating thing in the
world to me and I'd made this this big
rant and a bunch of people were like
[ __ ] you they're amazing when you think
back and all the times that you maybe
said something or reported news that
upset another major youtube power
players their story that stands out I
don't get excited about the prospect of
hurting someone's career or trying to
ruin them right we're talking about the
story I want to think the best about
someone but I'm going to cover it fairly
as the industry gets bigger we're gonna
see more stories like that especially
because we're talking about thousands
and thousands of new creators that are
getting millions of subscribers a lot of
which don't have proper teams around
them all right to tell them not to do
something incredibly stupid or once they
do something incredibly stupid what to
do and then even to in this particular
space sometimes you're incentivized to
do something that's of it and then the
bar for stupid just keeps getting lower
and lower higher and higher depending on
how you define it yeah I mean we saw
that with pranks it was escalating
normally then people start faking pranks
to the extreme then we saw people doing
insane and saying fake pranks and then
some people not realizing those were
fake pranks and then doing really
serious insane illegal [ __ ] and then
getting arrested when people talk [ __ ]
about drama I'm like we've we've seen a
worse side of YouTube let the youtubers
box each other I don't care I think
that's really interesting and no one's
gonna throw a fake bomb at someone in
public this next one is the hot one
sauce okay so I legally based off what I
saw I never say is just amazing mmm dope
so you've discussed crypto currencies
for
when Leon your show and back in November
tweeted the trick with big coin is to
only invest we could fully destroy you
financially and emotionally where do you
fall on cryptocurrency are you smashing
the bye-bye-bye button are you running
for the hills
no no I I'm personally have the the same
as the the Mark Cuban belief right it's
it's a new space it's a crazy space if
you have a 10% that you can throw into a
fire and not feel horrible about I feel
like that's the play two years ago right
it was like it was known by people but
it wasn't known by everybody when
everyone went back last Thanksgiving and
the grandma was asking them about
cryptocurrency that's when you know that
everything's different right and then
also when [ __ ] grandma two days later
starts giving you like Hottel advice
then you're like okay this is some crazy
[ __ ] I mean you don't know in general
what's gonna happen and I never give
advice but I know I'm excited anytime
anyone's trying to disrupt the way
things are
oh no I'm hungry
tell twist hurting it has some tang
something with a tea it's got some Wang
to it I feel I do every current segment
on our show called explain that Graham
where you do a deep dive on our guest
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context sob bust out the
laptop on a stool thank you very much
Steven this is dangerous and I'll show
you the picture moves dangerous you tell
me the bigger story is that yeah I've
been on social media for too long ma'am
first things first what do you that you
say this is your first cheap meal and
how long like five days so there I was
kind of okay I'm at the beginning of it
I just we were looking at a different
picture earlier today and I'm just like
oh my god I've just been I've been
throwing myself into videos so much and
I focused so much on one thing that I've
just this the whole thing is something
that I really haven't taken care of
listen I died on that you know when we
traded those pictures back and forth on
your show I looked at that and I was
like what the [ __ ] is YouTube done to me
like one of these things done to me like
I can't outrun it you know it ends up
being good because probably without me
seeing my footage I
would be completely complacent in my
regular PDS camera angle where I look
fine
but it really hides real life the idea
of me eating wings and then the pressure
of the internet it honestly does keep me
doing cardio four or five days a week
because I don't ever want the meme to be
a thing I don't ever want people to say
the wings caught up to Shawn like it
actually is something that I think about
in a very serious way the Internet is
not is not the nicest of places but that
can be kind of a motivating thing a
little bit but it's also like
bullying's awesome it's great right in
my head I'm like actually everything
good in my life I have because of like a
big negative thing or like a bully in
some aspect but I was like I'd also
don't want that quote out of context
where it's like Philip DeFranco supports
bullying yes yeah Shawn Shawn credits
fat shaming for his six-pack coma I'm
gluten pretty good he's got a little
little tank so against my better
judgment I want to take a wing to talk
about the political landscape under 18
and I say that because the internet
freaks the [ __ ] out in the most
obnoxious way even during relatively
light discussions obviously it can be
very polarizing especially when
someone's on Facebook doing [ __ ] all
caps crazy opinion but as long as you
throw out the facts this is what I
personally think what do you think some
people see it as a UH as kind of like a
gimme like I don't want I'm scared but
if we can't talk about things we can't
disagree about something and not [ __ ]
hate each other after I mean I don't
know what we're trying to do what do you
say to those critics the people that's I
like sorry for not trying to [ __ ]
shove my opinion down someone's throat
like a rope in what ways is the most
recent election affected your show and
the discourse surrounding it I feel like
the election kind of revamped the show
it was for a while a thing that I stayed
away from right it was to be the more
lower viewed videos you'd see kind of
discourse by people not really engaging
but the 2016 election among other things
that a lot of people caring about
politics and sharing their opinion more
and more so I have Hillary clean
Donald Trump to thank for my continued
career feel like I can't talk until the
next one dance in the Sun it's okay
Billy
I'll bill myself okay
as someone who's carved out a liminal
space between mainstream media and
internet culture I'm curious on your
perspective for what happens when the
YouTube universe bubbles up what
confuses you what amuses you what
infuriates you when say Logan Paul
becomes an international headline for
the reason that he became an
international headline originally
whether it be the suicide video the
tasing a rat after everything the
bragging after he came back from his
week vacation with a million new
subscribers that [ __ ] pisses me off
because I think that unfortunately is
the representative of YouTube to a good
number of people and unfortunately that
includes journalists who already had a
negative opinion of youtubers in the
first place there's a little bit little
it's a tingle now it's not a ting and it
also must be surreal when you become the
subject when that sort of thing happens
are you like oh hey my message is
getting out there or do you see it
getting muddled in the media
meat-grinder
it depends on who's doing it right there
there are a lot of journalists who will
take the story and they'll try and take
any quote they can get from you so that
you're saying some negative stuff about
YouTube despite what you're talking
about is maybe diversification I've had
that done but then I've seen more and
more whether it be full-on mainstream or
clogs taking people seriously you can
have differences of opinion but it's
really hard to argue the numbers
all right so this next one is the bomb
all right this is I don't want to put me
in my place man I'm feeling so confident
okay
[Music]
attack him it's got a belt angle it's
welcome I watch made a home
[Music]
okay we're second I thought you were
playing with me welcome to the
terrordome that's good ma'am no Scoob I
don't know why I'm looking like I have
[ __ ] electricity coming out my fingers
I like it I like it why are you obsessed
with MTV's the challenge oh my god I
don't back it up at all because they
took the concept of Survivor they're
like what if the same people come back
every year and there are just multi
season storylines hi there's probably a
cheaper way to pay for it mmm a lot of
saliva came into play there's what I got
this I got this
hmm die hard is it a Christmas movie or
not a Christmas movie yes very stupid
question is it is a constant argument
between my wife and I she is pure it's
not of course it is of course it is it
has everything in place as a UFC Fan
what's your take on these YouTube
personalities arranging boxing matches
with each other why not I mean if the
ksi Logan Paul thing happened and it was
the UFC or you could take some down to
the ground why do I know information
about Logan Paul being a [ __ ]
wrestler if you were putting together a
youtube fight card which two
personalities would you want to see Duke
it out as the main event I think we'd
all win if it was Jake Paul first Logan
pole two men enter one man leaves
whoo and they get the other person's
channel it's over it's a win-win all
right so this next one is Mad Dog 357
with number nine plutonium oh come on
[Music]
you're gonna be getting the whole thing
right I'm going wherever you go Philly
let's let me know my hmm got this so you
can't do what you do without being
comfortable with catching some Internet
shrapnel and I'm sure that there are
days where your Twitter mentions look
like a word stomach sorry which special
interest group considers Philly D public
enemy number one it's just the Internet
and it's probably a problem that's
become so normal to me the Internet in
general has normalized just extreme
reactions right and I'm just like oh
Internet Oh Internet I didn't listen
because I have nothing to prove alright
Philly you come in here you get through
it without some milk your whole team's
giving you high fives or whatever do
this a hundred and eight times alright
and then don't drink the milk okay and
then raise the ante alright but let the
record show are you without water
without milk so far I'm trying I'm
trying hey here's the thing after
watching the the Gabriel Iglesias
episode I watched Dax Shepard episode
has anyone ever gone through and not
drink anything it has happened a couple
of times does that mean a couple of
times let's never happen on the show as
far as the eating of the wings you want
to set a record of some sort oh you know
hey man you got me out here and and I
feel like I can contribute something to
this show and I want to leave a lasting
impression and I just want to know what
that is Dax Shepard brought out an extra
wing one time on the last wing but no
one's ever brought out two extra wings
on the last wing I feel like he should
not have on a youtube show an on YouTube
person have a youtube record Wow so I
would like I shouldn't say this before I
[ __ ] taste it I would like to try and
beat his record
I would like to beat this record and I'd
like to see I'd like to witness history
yes so this is the last dab we call it
the last dab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last way you got that to piece I just
did I throw right and followed it up
with an uppercut but I'll stick with it
oh there you go going in a mountain of
dab you know
we go filly Dean yeah okay John even
mine has don't burn my face off [ __ ]
there's more pleasant first unto bomb I
[Music]
don't know why I'm bouncing like that's
really [ __ ] cool off my stomach
alright filly d here we are at the final
stage ten scorching hot chicken wings in
your belly
not a drop of water or milk to chase it
but before we get you out of here I just
have one more question
I need a rant titled why I hate Costco
by Philip DeFranco what is your beef
with America's number one warehouse
store oh my god I've been outed as a
Costco hater you're not the only one
with a laptop full of secrets there's
just a lot of people and this is gonna
make me sound like a big [ __ ] elitist
at whatever I am I am an introvert I
feel uncomfortable around a lot of
people despite there being 15 people
around us that are taking pictures right
now and me feeling normal in this
situation cuz there's [ __ ] lights for
some reason but without in the real
world around thousands of people all at
the same time trying to get to the same
thing as me and then I talked to the
camera I talked to the world and I want
to chill with less than 10 people
day-to-day basis but also I gotta say
the the only times that I've ever really
gone to Costco or on the weekend so it's
just if you've been there it's a [ __ ]
madhouse I know that Costco it might
freak you out but you're not scared of
some hot chicken wings no water no milk
let the record show reppin hard for the
YouTube crowd we had now do we have
extras I don't I don't mean to mess up
your thing I need I'm not looking for a
championship belt Dom he's doing it for
this sport he got something yet - he
wants two extra wings oh no
dun-dun-dun I feel like I feel like I
should just one second it's it's a
little bit in the face mm-hmm it's a
little bit in the face but it's it's the
it's the stomach but I'm gonna have to
deal with it anyway right so it's good
it's good it's not me are you still
feeling good yeah let's do one drum one
flat okay pick them out filling dude but
these don't have anything on right
nothing you got address them yourself
hi sorry I know that you don't want your
show to be a competition but this is
just how I was built listen
it's how you play with the wings and
also it says mom you can't have like a
skinny guy have that record that's not
fair you let me know when what is that
how much it seems aggressive I think
that that's good okay and then I'll let
you do this if you like that's good
we're good all right for the people or
the people that's what I do what a
showman Philly D on his victory lap
clear and wings with the last dab Kate
I'm American I feel almost guilty but in
the same time not I know this will fly
flying a little close to the Sun hmm
go go I'm not crying I'm just sweating
for my eyes so impressive from this side
of the table and now there's nothing
left to do but roll out the red carpet
for you Philly D this camera this camera
or this camera let the people know what
you have going on in your life if you
want to watch new as that is as unbiased
as I can possibly try to make it and
then have an opinion to bounce off of
and then you want to have a conversation
in the comments down below go to
youtube.com slash Philip DeFranco
it's Philip with one L not a Philip with
two L's I don't know
that is I am so gonna regret that the
thing is the face is done I've killed my
taste buds long ago it's it's the throat
stomach situation that's starting to
catch up with you a little bit whoo I
love it
thanks for time yeah yeah hey what's
going on hot ones fans and Sean Evans
checking in if you enjoyed the video do
us a solid please subscribe
we're not above begging for clout over
here so you know what to do
smash that subscribe button with a
sledgehammer who appreciates you me